welcome here in warm welcome to this
North Sea Summit here in in Austin
the City of Austin is a is a city with
the rich European history influences
Belgian influences Dutch influences
French British and many other European
influences such as so many places in in
Belgium but above all one of the Cities
which is the main gateways to the
offshore energy industry that we see
developing as such a sprawling speed
over the last years
here in Austin we follow up to the first
North Sea Summit which took place in in
Edgeworth so first of all dear method
would like to to thank you for the
excellent initiative that you took in in
ashburg I really thank you for passing
the torch to us to to use the platform
that you uh that you created
we met in as work
since one year over one year we have
made such a such a progress first of all
while this Coalition of four countries
has has become a bit a bit larger
extremely happy to welcome Ireland
France
um Norway and our virtual North Sea
country of the Luxembourg
extremely happy to uh to have you uh to
have you here and I think this is a
moment uh more than ever this is a
moment where uh as European countries we
demonstrate what you are capable of we
demonstrate it to our citizens and to
our Enterprises and we demonstrated to
tackle one of the biggest challenges of
our times
first of all we showed that the climate
crisis can be addressed secondly we show
that we can pass from Innovation to
action
third we show that we can produce
affordable energy for our citizens and
for our companies and we also show that
we as Europeans we take our own destiny
in our own hands
let's face it the only way to achieve
real progress on transformation is by
working together as European countries
and when we work together we are capable
of so much
working together this is very concrete
this means building interconnections
strengthening our green electricity grid
we have achieved more than anyone could
have could have imagined and look at
what we did over the last year if we
would have said one year ago that we
would have gotten this far in in
disconnecting from fossil fuels from
Russia no one would have believed that
we would have been able to do this today
this Summit marks an important milestone
a milestone to make of the North Sea the
biggest green power plants in the world
we aim for a capacity of 130 gigawatts
by 2030 300 gigawatts by 2050. by then
we will be able to provide electricity
for 300 million households on the
European continent
our goal is to deliver a Greener Europe
Europe which is energy independent and
in Europe that can grow in a sustainable
way that can continue creating jobs and
especially that can keep heavy industry
chemistry and all these activities here
on the European continent Jerusalem we
are extremely happy to um to have you
here as a president of the of the
European commission we know that we can
count on you in pushing us and and being
ambitious in helping us in in
standardizing
um and really helping us to go from
Innovation to standardizing to uh to
implementing and and and we know that we
have you on our side and we're extremely
happy of the driving force that we have
shown over the past uh over the past
years
of course we cannot do this alone
you will see here heads of governments
heads of states
but the real Force we have is our
private sector and and I'm extremely
happy at this Summit to have more than
120 of our finance companies who are who
are present here uh who will be working
together
between them but also often in a
public-private partnership
to making sure that we can we can
realize the things that we announce very
often when we announce things it's very
good when you realize them this is where
we really make uh make the make the
effort so I would like to uh to thank
all of you and I will start with giving
the word to to Mata you uh did an
incredible effort last year in in
organizing it in Ashbrook we were really
impressed by the gigantic gigantic
turbines we wanted to show something
which was a bit impressive as well which
is our our ships but um really happy
method to have you uh back here and um
you that you you started this initiative
thank you so much last year we met in
SBI in Denmark to kick-start our
political vision for the north CAC green
power plant for Europe and thank you
Alexander for inviting us today to take
our vision further on now I think today
we are taking an important step in
realizing our common ambition nine
countries from the North Sea region are
committed to Offshore wind and green
transition
as the future of our energy Supply in
our countries we are raising the the bar
300 gigawatt of offshore
wind in the North Sea by
2050 the largest electricity system in
Europe it's offshore it's green and it
is European
last week the Danish government
committed to an even faster build out of
offshore wind a five-fold increase in
production from offshore wind we are
speeding up green transition in Denmark
and I think all of us needs to speed up
our green Ambitions for of course a
number of good reasons first of all
because of Russia's brutal war in
Ukraine it has made it absolutely clear
that we need to produce more energy
ourselves
we urgently need to combat climate
change for second reason and more green
energy will strengthen our energy
security as Europeans and of course also
provide reliable Energy prices for our
households and for our businesses but
they are still some barriers to the
green transition we must secure our
supply chains we have to build the
European industry stronger we need to
reduce the bureaucratic rules
um and we have to align
what we want when it comes to
biodiversity and the environment and the
Ambitions we have on on climate I think
all these are important discussions we
also have to do with our businesses so
we need to keep on going forward we have
to do it together and this is what we
seek to do today here so thank you once
again Alexander for inviting us
thank you uh thank you madam beautiful I
I talked about the leadership role you
you take and you've led us through the
different crises
um this crisis is one which we can use
to make a step forward and and really
happy that you um that with the plans
like the green deal and so on you shown
the direction extremely happy to have
you here among us thank you very much
Alexander thank you very much for
inviting me and for hosting us here in
austenda the city by the sea
and indeed as you said a lot has changed
and improved since last year when we had
our first meeting in iceberg
um we should not forget it was the year
of a severe energy crisis that was
triggered by the Russian war
but we have managed together to get rid
of our dependency on Russian fossil
fuels
we have Diversified away from Russia to
Reliable partners
the European people have saved 20 of
their energy consumption but most
importantly we have massively invested
in Renewables
so despite this crisis we managed to
keep the economy growing on one hand but
on the other hand we were able to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions two figures are
here important while globally the
greenhouse gas emission did rise last
year by one percent in the European
Union the greenhouse gas emission were
reduced by two and a half percent
in other words there was a formidable
boost in this year of Crisis to
renewable production in the European
Union
we have doubled the additional
deployment of renewable energy last year
and we have for the very first time
generated more electricity from wind and
sun compared to gas
Renewables are crucial for us to reach
our goals in 2050. it's all about
speeding up and as you know the European
Union has just raised its 2030 targets
for Renewables from 32 percent up to
more than 42 percent so I very strongly
welcome the end declaration it's great
it's doubling down on the targets set in
aceberg for offshore wind production and
it will give us give us all the wind we
need in our sales to set the course onto
climate neutrality
the European commission will help to
deliver on these targets
and this is why we have the green deal
industrial plan
all our proposals to implement this
industrial plan are on the table now
first The Net Zero industry act that
will help to create a conducive
environment
for clean tech industry
it will support Innovation and very
important the manufacturing at scale of
cleantech
second our reform of the electricity
Market design will incentivize the use
of renewable compared to fossil fuels
and third are critical raw materials act
act aims at securing the supply of the
materials
that are so badly needed to build wind
turbines and other clean tech
one very last point on renewable
hydrogen
I'm very glad that we have stepped up
the ambition on renewable hydrogen green
hydrogen can be the game changer for
Europe our Industries and our economy
and the North Sea region has the
potential to produce massive amounts of
green hydrogen and to become the main
Corridor for imports so of course I am
very happy and I would like to invite
the countries here today to work on
cross-border hydrogen projects the
commission is ready to support as much
as possible and in parallel we will make
sure that the hydrogen bank that we will
create is operational by the end of this
year to create a full-fledged European
hydrogen Market
so in some Europe has become the house
of Renewables and the North Sea is
becoming the PowerHouse of New York
thank you
thank you Emmanuel please
foreign
European
[Music]
info consolidation Excellence the
cooperation
is
capacity production
foreign
Quaker this is
a determinants
in foreign
Mercy they're Olaf you know the Belgian
Coast quite quite well by now a few
months ago you were in uh to visit our
LNG infrastructure we've had a very
long-standing partnership on the on the
energy domain and and I'm sure that um
maintaining economic activity and
definitely heavy industry in Europe is
for you also priority
John dunk
s versus
continent
Al
foreign
trophy
office foreign
foreign
and the Albert
thank you Olaf
you technically are not really a North
Sea country either but wind energy is
something which Ireland knows knows
extremely extremely well mostly onshore
up to uh up to now but offshore
potential of course there's a huge one
and extremely happy that you're part of
this Coalition now as well go ahead
thank you Alexander uh
in
Austin's Declaration of Shinu hurricane
my thanks to Alexander for the
invitation to be here today's Summit and
the opportunity for us in Ireland to
join the Austin declaration and I really
want to thank Belgium for its leadership
in taking this initiative but also when
it comes to renewable energy as I flew
in this morning it was fascinating to
see the number of buildings here in
Austin that have solar panels on their
roofs small buildings and large
buildings and also to see the amount of
offshore winds that Belgium has already
so I think you're showing a lot of
leadership already
I believe our attendance here at this
meeting eight governments the European
commission the United Kingdom
represented as well a ministerial level
and 120 companies shows a very real
shared commitment to accelerating the
transition to Green Energy Future and
harnessing the immense potential of
offshore Renewables when it comes to
climate the science is very clear the
facts are also very clear on the ground
our world is getting warmer severe
weather events are becoming more
frequent and we have no time to waste an
acting we have to be degeneration that
turns the tide on climate change and
biodiversity
some of you will know Mary Robinson
former president of Ireland and former
un High Commissioner for uh for refugees
and um
she says so human rights to other and
she says that um
there are two things that were on the
cusp of
um one is around the cost of climate
disaster
the others that were on the cusp of
deploying the technological advances
that allow us to avoid all of that and
we need to make sure that one gets ahead
of the other that we make the changes
necessary before it's um too late and I
think as others have said that's really
reinforced by what's happening with
Russia and the extent to which energy
has been weaponized so today's
discussions
um are going to be with industry reps
and we'll emphasize the development of
Supply chains needed to honor our and
Achieve our renewable energy objectives
we're all making already making
significant progress with the framework
on the North Seas energy cooperation and
a memorandum of understanding between
its members in the UK is now in place
and today's Austin declaration allows us
to go beyond the North Sea to The Wider
North Seas including the Irish sea the
Celtic Sea and the Atlantic Ocean and
Ireland as a country is relatively small
but our seas are greater seven times
greater than our land mass and that's
what we hope to bring to the table here
today we also must ensure that
biodiversity is protected in whatever we
do that our rural local and Coastal
communities benefit from opportunities
and also the green jobs that will arise
so really looking forward to working
closely with our regional partners and
the European commission to build the
offshore grids and electricity
interconnection that will benefit us all
and that's going to enable us to trade
offshore renewable energy of the rest of
Europe but most of all for our citizens
at home and our businesses ensuring that
we have security of supply and
affordable and predictable prices into
the future and all done with the benefit
to our environment so thank you very
much
yeah thank you
um
Logan
[Music]
Society
foreign
the problem that we have is when we see
if it's the the solar energy or if it's
also the wind energy that the production
and I'm very happy that also some of the
colleagues raised up the topic we see
that the energy production we are very
dependent we saw it with Russia coming
from one kind of the products now we see
with the LNG even its trusted Partners
but it comes from the other side of the
world or from the south or from the west
and so I think it's very important then
if we want to continue in that that we
also take it as a priority solar panels
we were leaders we were leaders now
China is a leader
when we see also the turbans we have if
you look the biggest companies very few
are European companies the Chinese again
we have a relation with China which is
for the moment okay but tomorrow also be
less good if that's the fact again we
need really strategic autonomy on our
economy and also putting priority on the
production of European made in Europe
also on the capacities of the needed
machine and genes to to do it so I just
want to thank you again for inviting us
here we see us we see all of us that the
energy cry the climate crisis sorry is
something we I I remember we watched it
on TV it was in Nicaragua it was in
Australia it was in New Zealand it's now
it's in Europe and it's not yesterday or
today or or tomorrow or in five years it
is now that we have to act and even if
it's not too late so I really hope that
we will continue you can you can count
on on Luxembourg and as you said before
we already have a project we know the
project we signed with with standard
Mark and you will have an
we don't have to admit we don't have the
Luxembourg C and the Moselle and the
sower is not big enough to have wind
miles on them but if we are useful we
will continue to be useful and this is
also an invitation for other colleagues
who have no C's
you don't need to have disease if you
have capacities to do common things we
will make bigger things together so
thank you very much for the invitation
equality
last week
I personally saw how much work energy
companies and grip operators are already
doing to prepare us for a philosophy
future
they are building wind farms they are
starting operations and developing at
the same time the infrastructure we need
so that Europe can benefit from the
North Sea as a natural source of energy
the lion link project which we are now
seeing today and it is to connect the
Netherlands and the United Kingdom is a
good example of these efforts
and they are sorely needed for that car
from Ireland the ipcc's recent work
shows we need to step up our climate
efforts
and that means moving towards
sustainable energy supplies
I would also add that the Russian
invasion of Ukraine has made it all the
more urgent
we have to make sure Putin no longer has
the means to exert pressure on us by
turning off the gas step
and producing clean energy is the best
way to achieve this
and the enormous potential of the North
Sea region is indispensable here and
thank you Ursula from a life in the
European commission that you are willing
to do everything to support that whole
endeavor
and that's why it's good that we've come
together here in osender we're following
up on the first and successful North Sea
Summit under metaphors leadership in
ashberg last year
and the France luxembourgs you have
Kingdom norm and Ireland are joining us
today in our ambition to turn the North
Sea into the green and an engine of
Europe
and with Ireland and with Luxembourg we
are moving beyond the North Sea but
still discussing the North Sea and
yonash you being here from Norway
but also the other Kingdom now being
part of this group means also that we
are moving beyond a little bit the
European Union in its strict borders
and by expanding now this North Sea
Coalition we are also boosting I believe
our joint efforts last year the
Netherlands we already raised our
national Target to 21 gigawatts by 2030
and there's almost 80 percent of our
current total electricity consumption
but here's an important point if they
are really to produce our own wind
turbines and batteries in Europe we
indeed as a minimum concept we need to
be less dependent on one single supplier
for our critical raw materials
and it is Olive Schultz who is
consistently pleading to remove barriers
in permitting procedures so we can speed
up our energy projects
it's important here I believe that we
strive to write balance between nature
fisheries and energy
it's not only north three countries that
today's Agreements are connecting we can
also see and use the North Sea wind
energy to produce green hydrogen which
could provide renewable energy to other
countries in Europe so I really believe
Alexander that meetings like today are
vital in this to share plans and see
where we can join forces
so I'm looking forward to our
discussions but again thank you for
organizing this follow-up meeting and to
bring us together here but also for this
very warm welcome you provide us thank
you
thank you
darionas you've been a long-term partner
of the European Union in in all
questions related to energy
and especially last year and and I think
there's a warm thank you from all of us
in the role that Norway has played in in
helping us to get through this through
this crisis but there's so much more
that we can that we can do and I'm
really looking forward to have you part
of this Coalition with with all the
possibilities you have in offshore wind
but actually much more than that
thank you Alexander it's good to be the
new kid on the Block
with my friends around this North Sea uh
emerging biggest energy region
potentially in the world
Norway is as you said the largest
provider of energy to Europe uh that
situation was emphasized during this
last year we've been able to increase
our
export our gas by some eight to ten
percent that represent 100 terawatt
hours of extra energy into Europe
and we will be able to maintain that for
the next few years so that we can
forward the transition
but we have a lot more to contribute
because we have a coastline
and we have wind and we have expertise
in building heavy things that can stand
the pressure from wind and oceans so we
are engaging into offshore wind
enthusiastically
and today this morning Ursula we signed
a green alliance between Norway and the
European Union we worked on that for a
year
Norway has integrated our objectives
to reach Paris obligations with the
European Union these are our partners we
have integrated economies
so we want to reach the targets with the
European Union partners and with this
green Alliance we really
exemplify how to do that
and one important part is to take this
Paradox of Russia's Invasion it has
actually accelerated Europe's
Independence towards energy security
with the renewable push and we want to
be part of that
so there are a lot of Dimensions here
where we have expertise offshore wind
especially the floating windmills which
have to build on expertise from heavy
structures out offshore
hydrogen production production be it
green or in the intermediary time blue
namely by gas where we extract the CO2
store it 2000 meters under the seabed
and Norway has done that for 20 30 years
we know the technology and how to do it
so our ambitions
are also High by 2040 we aim for 30
gigawatt that is about 1500 windmills
and for what is linked to the southern
part of Norway we want to see that in
the Norse perspective and then we will
follow up along our Coast towards the
baron Sea and Arctic Waters because we
also need this energy there
I would also like to emphasize that we
as governments should help push this
industry to get off the ground but the
key here and the core is the private
sector
and I would like to Salute You Alexander
for having followed up what meta did
last year in SBI and here it is even
more impressive the number of companies
with world-class expertise I'm happy to
see there are 10 to 15 Norwegian
companies and they will contribute
actively in the side events which are
around here so we are building value
chains they are European they are norsee
and they will really make a difference
Norway is really happy to be part of it
and I hope that we will be able to one
day invite you to a similar gathering at
our Shores
and then we will make the windmills turn
thank you
thank you after all of this you might
have some some questions but before we
go to the questions we will proceed to
the signing of the Austin's declaration
um and so two representatives of the
Austin's huge city council lens and
Kiara will will bring you the
Declaration and we'll ask each one of
you to sign it
give them an Applause first of all
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
okay thank you give them another
Applause
[Applause]
excellent job Austin declaration to
summarize it from from announcements to
implementation for a Greener a more
sustainable and a more independent
Europe
hey
[Applause]
all right
any questions please take it over but um
I have a first question from yala Franke
vitiam
prime minister Belgium is considering
legal a legal procedure against France
concerning the construction of a wind
farm in the North Sea at Dunkirk
that's not really a proof of
collaboration and stepping up ambition
what is your position on that legal
procedure and more broadly what what are
the concrete measures or deals you have
now that the actual speed up in advance
you said that it has to go further than
only showing Ambitions what are these
concrete steps
well first of all in in in planning of
shore wind Parks we need to talk and and
between Belgium and France were
invincing very intensive talks on on
this new
um very big windmill park off the coast
of uh of Don karke and I'm quite sure we
will come to an agreement which is
satisfying for both uh for both
countries when I say from from
announcement to to uh to action
what we need to do is to standardize and
industrialize
this offshore wind industry is one which
is very much in Innovation driven it
will remain Innovation driven but the
biggest gain today is in speeding up the
building if we want to speed up the
building you need to standardize it it
means standardizing the zoning
standardizing the tendering
standardizing all to the also the
security measures that you need to to
take to secure these these industries
standardizing the financial model which
makes it easier to uh to uh to finance
it and then synchronize between us if we
decide to build all at the same time the
industry gets in trouble if we plan it
in the right way we can scale up today
we have a capacity to build
approximately seven gigawatts per year
if we want to achieve our Ambitions we
need to get to 20 gigawatts per year it
is possible with our private sectors but
we need to help and this is to me the
main goal of this Summit is announcement
yes but especially synchronizing better
and making sure that together we can go
from from announcements to speed
I have a second question by Ola reborg
Dr
um
last week a documentary by four
television stations from Denmark Sweden
Norway and Finland documented how
Russian vessels have been mapping the
locations of all windmill farms in Hall
of Scandinavia along the coast down to
Belgium and and Holland and all the way
to Britain and and I think they've even
been in Ireland so my question to you is
you've now been talking about how you
were going to develop the North Sea as
the PowerHouse but what are you going to
do to protect that infrastructure for
Thunder line the EU direction for 2008
about infrastructure is quite old and
and not done to this so how are you
going to to change this to increase the
protection of of the bills that you do
and even for I'm curious about the
Franco German engine on in all this is
this uh National thing as it is today or
do you foresee that in the future we
need European Corporation even European
military cooperation or in other ways in
order to protect these windmills that we
win Farms that we do in the North Sea
thank you
yes we we have followed the situation
very closely because we know that our
critical infrastructure is under threat
and we know it since the we have
experienced the sabotage of North stream
pipeline
last year so this is a reason why we
have stepped up in the European Union
our actions concerning preparedness
concerning the response and the
cooperation that is possible cooperation
between member states of course as you
said on EU level here we are at the
moment being working on a stress test
program for the worst case mainly in the
infrastructure we had a first stock
taking in April and we will take the
results to identify our weaknesses but
of course also strengthen our resilience
the second part which is very important
is not only the European Union is
working on this topic but we are teaming
up with NATO
and with NATO we have created a Joint
Task Force basically working on the same
principles I've just explained But it
includes the whole possible range of
threats for example also the topic of
cyber threats
um concerning our key sectors and namely
also of course energy
the EU NATO experts are at the moment
being working on a program for
coordinated resilience and the results
of this we will present to you the
leaders at the NATO Summit which will
then take place in July so you'll see
we've really stepped up because we know
it's crucial and critical that we are up
to date there
just one word to say that we do believe
this is a matter of security for all of
us
so we are available and by the way we
coordinated this type of effort with no
way and some other players when when it
happened indeed
a few months ago and and we are still
available it's part of our national
defense strategy to be precisely
involved in the defense of
critical infrastructures for energy and
Telecommunications and it's part as well
of the topics we put on the table on
this European political community in
Prague it raised as one of the critical
topics and this is something we will
discuss with in Casino as well with uh
with all the players it seems that the
concept of oh sorry please we have not
much to add from my side just saying
that we already invited NATO and
European Union to work on this topic
which also love on the line already
reported and they are already working to
find the procedure how we cooperate in
this field and also on the national
level we took a lot of decisions how we
will be more able to understand the
situation and all the dangers
cooperating with others especially with
Norway in one case and so you can be
sure this is a question of high priority
it seems that the concept of scientific
research is quite a broad one in in the
North in the North Sea but this is one
of the topics which is part of this
Austin declaration is that we need to
look at building and security by Design
I think the new the new Investments we
do in offshore wind in cables in
pipelines need to be secured by Design
this was not a priority 15 years ago
it's quite clear that it will be
priority in years to come
next question is by Alexandra
question a question maybe to the Danish
Prime Minister
um can you tell us more about the
results of the investigation in the
north stream pipeline attack because
it's been a while we're not getting any
results and don't you think that's not
showing a complete transparency that
could be playing into Putin's hands
thank
you thank you for that question
um
as you probably know there's still an
investigation going on on this topic it
was quite dramatically when when we
found out about it but the investigation
is not finished yet and therefore the
authorities are not able yet to say word
about it
um
but and we don't know when the results
will be there or if there will be a
result so we have to wait a bit more
well I think a lot of us have been
asking questions about
since the beginning of the war will this
be
um
uh in the hands of Putin would this
support uh the wordings from from Moscow
and and in all questions I don't believe
in that way of seeing it because
um if the authorities are not capable of
saying anything about the investigation
yet then they are not ready to do it and
and in our countries we have to respect
of course that the authorities have some
measures and have certain decisions to
make and the political level have other
measures and other
decisions to make so no I I don't I
don't agree with you but
um the investigation is still going on
France
foreign
[Music]
sure
economies
[Music]
account
opportunity
[Music]
said the notifications
for the next question please
this is
foreign
[Music]
Zola
February
foreign
of
the Irish Times
hi a question for Tisha Cleveland
we've heard a lot of talk about
Ireland's potentially being a Powerhouse
in the export of wind energy I wonder if
we could give any figures in terms of
what that would mean to the Irish
economy can you give any sense of the
size of potential exports like revenues
the jobs this might mean and then also
what level of public investment is
required to bring the National Grid up
to scratch to actually be able to handle
something like that thanks
so Ireland as a country requires about
six
um six gigs of electricity to satisfy
our own needs but that's going to
increase dramatically as we Electrify
our Transport Systems and more and more
industry goes electric as well but the
Target that we've set for Renewables for
offshore wind is 30. so roughly five
times the amount of energy that we
currently use and that's a hugely
ambitious Target but one that we believe
we can achieve it's not just about after
a wind although it'll be mainly about
after wind it's also about solar as well
as on Sherwin 2 and
um using that for our own energy needs
but also to produce green hydrogen which
is going to be one of the fuels of the
Futures the president commissioner said
also synthetic Aviation Fields so that
we can continue to fly maybe not as
frequently as we do now but still when
we need to and also to make green
fertilizer which I think would be very
beneficial for agriculture in particular
because at the moment we use
fertilizers that are nitrogen based in
oil-based and if we could change to
Green fertilizers that would be um that
would be much better for lots lots of
different reasons
um when it comes to the investment we're
going to need a combination of public
investment and private investment it's
going to take many billions uh tens of
billions we believe
um but crucially I think we need to
understand that this form of public
investment is public investment that
will pay for itself because people and
businesses pay for electricity uh
ultimately the capital cost is recovered
and you then start to make a profit so a
lot of public investment that we make is
really important and really valuable but
it never turns of profit investment in
energy will turn a profit so the first
couple of years the first couple of
decades it covers the capital cost but
after that it becomes profit making so
it's a huge Economic Opportunity as well
and let's not forget that the fuel
the fuel the powers with energy is free
not like all their gas it's free and all
you need to do is install the equipment
and install the grid although the grid
is going to be a huge job and I think
what we're going to need is a master
grid a super grid for all of Europe if
you think of our grids that we have at
the moment like roads we still are
running off local and Regional roads and
now we need to build European energy
motorways essentially to harness that
offshore energy and bring it all over
Europe
next question by Tim morise by RTL
okay so Luxembourg is currently
importing 80 of its electricity from
abroad how can Nations like Luxembourg
smaller Nations profit from this
Corporation is that going to mean 100
green energy Import in the future
so I'm very proud to to tell you that we
were able last year for the first time
in our history to have renewable energy
covering all the private households this
is new for Luxembourg this was not the
case before I think that's to say that
the whole economy and Industry will be
covered by renewable energy tomorrow
would be a lie so we are looking for all
the opportunities that we can have to
see this with Denmark where I told you
that we signed an agreement this is why
I'm sitting here where we try to find to
push also the colleagues so it is
important for the continent but it also
important for for luxembach we so how it
happened I just want to remind because I
think we forgot that a few months ago we
were asking ourselves when will be a
possible blackout on energy we all
forgot but that was the situation we had
where we were and thank you usually for
all you did was the commissions to see
how we would be able to continue to
produce to have energy and trying not to
punish or to do obligations but trying
to to
sensibilize people to reduce the energy
and we were able we were able so I think
it will be a mixture of uh
renewable energies from here renewable
energies as I told you before with
initiatives that we want to have with
solar air panels also on the different
households and the different projects
with Denmark and with other countries
also the hydrogen is a future where we
have to see where we can work together
there are some energy sources as you
know we don't believe in it we don't
think that they are sure and and green
and but there are so many opportunities
that's the reason why I'm so happy to be
here today to support this kind of
initiatives
next question by petroleum Bruce and pay
no or not
that
is
hello everybody my name is
my question is really foreign
building all these wind Parks costs a
lot of nitrogen
emission
it means that a lot of
Builders
cannot get the permits they need and
it's not going as fast as they like
I know this is one of the things that
the member states need to do but can the
commission help out a little bit in this
how do you check all this problem yes if
I understand you well it's about the
permitting processes that um last too
long still today this is the reason why
together we have introduced an emergency
law last year that says basically that
member states are able to Define
so-called go-to areas and if these areas
are defined
there is legally an overriding public
interest
and this makes it possible that the
permission the permitting processes can
be reduced to less than one year
this was the emergency regulation we did
last year now we have transformed this
emergency or yeah transformed the
emergency regulation into the so-called
red three renewable energy director
three this has just been agreed so it's
now cast in law and this gives a big
advantage to have slim and
fast permitting procedures for for
example the the building of wind parks
that are necessary
have a last question by
siemen ecken nrk
yes thank you it's a question for the
commissioned president
Norway has wanted to look for more oil
and gas in vulnerable Arctic regions and
this was a complex issue in the talks
before The Pact that you signed today
and the green Alliance now we have
stated several times how thankful you've
been for a Norway's support but how
green our country is Norway really in
these new ongoing decisions about the
new energy a reality in your view
so in the many talks that I had with you
Jonas I could see how genuine and true
the very ambitious green transformation
is
and yes of course you are a resource
rich country what for example gas is
concerned but it is impressive to see
the um the enormous investment you're
doing in green energies and the green
Alliance is basically working together
on all different strands for the green
transformation be it supporting each
other when it comes to Global targets or
supporting each other for example when
it comes to developing the Renewables
but also supporting each other when it
comes to research and development
carbons capture and storage is a very
interesting field that we're working on
together
a green hydrogen has been mentioned
already and over time of course it's
important for us that for example the
infrastructure we built is one day
hydrogen ready so you see a whole
concept behind it it's the very first
green Alliance the European Union has
with a European country it's only the
second we have at all
so and there's a good reason why we
choose and we're glad to have Norway by
our side
and the Arctic discussions
we found I think a very good balance
between
the two necessary
points and this is summarized in the
green Alliance the balance that is
necessary to protect of course the
Arctic region but also to have the
necessary approach to existing fields
that you're looking at
well I I support everything the
commission president said let me just
say that Norway is in transition
from oil and gas to renewable
and I think we're all safe by making
that transition in a responsible manner
and half of the increase of Norway's gas
export to Europe this last year comes
from a site outside hummerfest which is
definitively in the Arctic it's LNG
coming into European ports
but that site at homefest is at the same
time known for extracting CO2 and
depositing that under the seabed for
eternity which is a technology which is
now being highlighted
so uh I really believe that we have to
be partners in this if we do a
transition by Closing one chapter one
day to open a new one the next day we
will fail and I think one part of the
vulnerability for Europe last year was
that when Russian gas disappeared there
was not enough renewable to fill the
space now we are moving ahead
impressingly to fill that space
and Norway will do its part in that
green transition
okay thank you
um Don't Run Away there is a press
conference of the energy ministers as
well and it would be sad if they would
have an empty room so please stay around
if I can just ask my colleagues to do a
large group picture together with our
two representatives of the of the of the
youth Council
and then we will move out
[Music]